après 2005 il y a beaucoup d'argent qui
a qui est arrivé dans les dans les
quartiers on a rénové beaucoup de
quartiers ça fait même l'objet de de
films bâtiment 5 de de la jli par
exemple qui raconte la destruction d'un
bâtiment il y a eu effectivement les les
les 12 milliards dont vous parlez c'est
beaucoup moins que l'argent qui est
injecté pour les Jeux Olympiques qui
vont durer 3 semaines enfin passons en
effet il y a eu une rénovation urbaine
et je je pense que mon mon mon acolyte
sera plus précis que moi mais
semble-t-il on a changé les bâtiments on
n pas changé la vie des gens ça c'est le
premier point et le deuxième
point en juillet 2023 la presse
s'interroge qu'est-ce qui se passe
pourquoi il y a ces immeutes et je
voudrais juste vous citer très très très
vite de deux phrases l'une de Jean-Louis
borlau pas la peine de de le présenter
qui nous dit quand ça a commencé à aller
mieux au milieu des années 2010 on a
arrêté de s'occuper des banlieux ce
n'était plus un problème un peu plus bas
dans le même article un ex-préfet de scè
Saint-Denis dont on n pas le nom mais on
peut deviner assez facilement qui il est
nous dit cette chose extrêmement
importante il nous dit en fait une
génération aura été sacrifiée les 15 17
ans c'estàdire les émeutiers qui
constituent le gros des hmeutiers sont
les oubliés de la politique de la ville
c'est-à-dire qu'au moment où on a
baissé la politique de rénovation
urbaine d'égalité des chances et cetera
et cetera c'est une génération qui
quelques temps plus tard